che per questo posto spaventoso sembra
che sia la parte abbandonata dell'hotel
paura rotto benvenuti solida storia oggi
nuovissima è che i pur rompete il rum e
molto speciale perché dovremmo scappare
da un hotel
ci sono delle cose su per trani sarà
anche dei cattivi vogliono rinchiudersi
dentro l'hotel il tuo bastarà super
divertente ma che mi raccomando lasciate
un mi piace questo che volete vedere
altre speciali che non mi seguite al
caso di taranto vera signora artistico
di preti pop corn e iniziamo subito con
loro tre schede c'è quale l'hotel devo
nella stanza d'hotel era un biglietto
non lo so esploriamo di fianco al
manager di sales manager è impazzito e
si è rinchiuso dentro l'hotel cosa
dobbiamo fare
qui c'è una porta andiamo a vedere mi
piace il mio vestito a guardarlo sta
parlando in questo modo ecco il bagno a
uomo vestito celeste con dovrebbero
essere degli stivali quello che ci è
successo è esploso qualcosa ci pone
sopra graziosissima come è fatto trovare
dovuto monello sistema di misurazione ha
detto di stare attenti ai laser o carico
qua bisogna stare molto attenti andare
piano piano ok al bayern ma ho fatto la
capriola in questa volta faccio le
capriole voi lo sapete e le altre mappe
non mi succede
tantissimi lavorativa indiano è ovvio la
novità è finalmente ha cambiato la
maglietta guardate maiese gialla è uno
che sta accadendo
[Musica]
ok è come si fa salire la adesso io
prima sono riuscito ma poi sono caduta
[Risate]
ha ucciso non ci si riusciva solo so che
non lo vedete evitare la giu vediamo
come cadere arrivare qua salviamo
arrivando
[Musica]
come bellico salariale aspettando che
cos'è mai si può andare a pia sammartano
tornati nella parte dell'hotel ha detto
che il manager ha messo un sacco di
trappole sembra difficilissimo
lasciate un mi piace per portarsi per
una pratica della nostra volta ha
funzionato lasciate un mi piace arresto
e vediamo che ci porta vitale si butta
direttamente rimandata al massimo sei
riuscito a superare tutta la voglia
guarda sono fatto vivo anch'io rientrare
in questa porta ma non posso dovete far
dare adesso io andrei avanti
no a questa parte ti sei salvato per un
pelo non ci credo potra superare tutto
io resto qui mi godo lo spettacolo di
come fa ogni volta sta lasciando
sfracellarsi a riga è difficilissimo che
sarà davvero un bite pure la berlina con
dei giovani
adesso no no non andare lì io sono tutto
di qua e un po di riposo sono sicuro
sono sicuro
o no questi sono i miei preferiti
ma che bel c'è scritto che l'ascensore
non funziona dobbiamo prendere l'uscita
di per cento che senti sono sicuro che
hanno forzato dai arrivo arrivo con le
uscite di emergenza è bravo ma lei è
riuscita in questa crisi che questa
mezza per questa qui dove sono state
loro è una canzone o no hay sono caduto
non mi sono attaccato bene alle scale
dai puoi farcela io evito andare il gelo
fatta e ecco se la porta noi usiamo
nella piscina dell'hotel cos'è questo
rumore di elettricità ma ho preso che
cosa hai fatto preso meno una bibita non
commento neanche come si prende e va beh
ma niente non riesco a passare questo
caso del porsi un patto forte e si è
prosciugata la piscina sono anch'io
adesso il piccino come si aspetta prima
un costante guarda
ecco qua brigati processo scelta di
nuovo grazie dove siamo adesso
ma quando lo so dovete di tutto io non
ti vedo siamo nella caldaia conteggiate
quest'anno ad aieta testamento non si
poteva saltare deve saltare in uno dei
quadratini piano attento attenta
sentissimo dai cro
bisogna saltare velocemente però non
abbiamo vendere prima tu aiuto ma lo
dobbiamo andare insieme perché adesso
sul k9 no
ok meno male ho salvato dove la vita le
vediamo vitale quante volte muore
vediamo ma che guarda sono bravissimi ma
è bravo per cui puoi farlo proprio per
poter saltare velocemente perché la donò
allora devo stare devo aspettare un
attimo che risale non ci credo come no
che non sono ancora caduta e ora dice
che c'è molto caldo qua beh
effettivamente da come nero la caldaia
dorico entrando adesso anno che voglio
bene
inizia andare attento che il pavimento e
lava veramente resto persona questo
nuovo vestito sembra tipo più agile non
so perché dico supereroe salviamo e
attento come evitare che vi sono quindi
qualità evita ai pezzi giavazzi gialli
devo evitare al piano piano piano piano
da questa settimana è capitale già morto
si no ecco vitale lo vedete siamo se si
riesce
piano piano piano piano piano piano a e
ci sono riuscito dai ce la puoi fare tu
così salvo e salvato la vita
no ok ci sono altri tool di qua bene
vediamo che cosa c'è qua adesso buono
tardani scattate a muro che succede in
questo muro i muri quito dove stiamo
andando adesso cosa fa la sogno
diventare un acrobata è un po difficile
bravo finalmente c'è voluto un sacco di
tempo
qua devo fare in essi di famiglia rabbi
rotto piano meno lineare si sta attenta
per fortuna chiamiamola sensore un
ascensore ha detto che non funzionava
prima vediamo se funziona adesso sì
tutti dove ci porterà questo ascensore
non paura rotto e rotola sensore per
fortuna non sono caduta vitale purtroppo
l'abbiamo perche sono questo verbo le
non riesce a superare una pappa piano
piano saliamo su dove andare qua no
brava atleta a sono di nuovo nello
termine sentiamo cosa dice il bene e per
questo posto spaventoso sembra che sia
la parte abbandonata dell'hotel quadra
che cos'è e tutto rosso non mi dire che
devo andare qua dentro aiuto fatemi
entrare soltanto dalla the avermi
salvato nel caso no non c'è solo terzo
ok dove secondo la bocca a bocca
siamo nuovamente dentro qualcuno in uno
squalo e questa cosa qui salvare ok
siamo dentro una buca non so se la bocca
di un vostro che cosa brava anche dai
fatto parte un aiuto ce n'è fatto sono
riuscito nel frattempo mia testa
trovando breva si no spiace capodanno
perché quando cammini quati rallenta
tipo gelatinoso tutto ok ce l'ho fatta
trovare ma non era affatto per fortuna
sono riuscito ad avvicinarmi ancora un
po ok cielo quasi fatta bravi sera la
mappa è stato difficile ma ce l'ho fatta
forse la devo chiamare l'assessore vita
lerici tendere a qualsiasi altro
ascensore che ci troviamo dentro una
storia destro sarebbe bello che successo
ei ma si è incastrato lasciato la serata
la cessione
tutto succede
sono rimasta chiusa dentro un assessore
si è pagato no vabbè questo è uno dei
miei incubi reali rimanere chiusa dentro
un ascensore questo deve aprire la porta
siamo una guarda aiuto
evitare solo tu questo albergo dieci
morti ci siamo un paio d'ore e vitale
sono pronto pratico fuori salva mio per
l'assessore duranti salvatore sono
salvato il risultato finale tele limato
incastrata là dentro per tutto il tempo
ma adesso dovete più contare
dobbiamo salire però aspetta forse
meglio salire uno alla volta nel caso
che rimaniamo molto grati aspetta vado
prima in senato ok ora questa linea
anche tu non sono rimasto bloccato
no ma come se è rimasto bloccato
adesso allora devo scendere a salvarti
in qualche modo come fai a scendere non
c'è nessun bottone mi sa che non possono
al bar
io sono rimasto bloccato nell'ascensore
nessuno anzitutto che ti può salvare il
posto tornare in b va bene ma se arriva
qualcuno nel gioco
vabbè andiamo qua nella ventilazione wow
www cos'è
forse sì stiamo sull'uscita forse sono
riusciti a scappare no mi dispiace che
tu sei rimasto incastrato nel nostro
stare non puoi scappare come uomo andai
a mi odia per ritirare cosa brava mio
nome non certo l'ultimo l'ultimo è molto
positivo saltare non ti preoccupare
questo stare le tanto ti succeda niente
ma piano piano e adesso dove bisogna
andare e forse lì bisogna ok ok
astronomi non si limita però ad
aumentare 0 porto dobbiamo andare qui
sulle scale quasi la piattaforma di un
elicottero
guarda l'impegno tel che bello vedere
nota il gigante da qua e là family forse
devo scappare
forse quando guardate vedo che c'è il
medaglione forse con il medaglione per
vincere vediamo prendiamo il medaglione
wow si sono bravissima ed ecco l'hotel
da fuori era e no tre mappe però le
dispiace che vita le rivolte sono state
un bel mi piace ora vi lasciamo qui
quattro case sterline su cui cliccare
provvedere i nostri altri video cade su
quella che preferite vuole navigare ciao